[Musique]
pour les enfants bonsoir
regardez ce joli petit panier rond savez
vous ce que saint patron oui c'est un
panier pour mettre le pain non c'est
encore mieux
et ce soir nous allons jouer au
corbillon tous ensemble c'est un jeu de
société tranquille et robe rose en
europe
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
moi ce que j'aime le mieux c'est de
laver les dents et moi c'est de faire la
toilette de ma poupée caprice allons
apporter jaillit vous voilà propre à
présent
[Musique]
bonsoir
ro ça sent bon le sens fonds propres
c'est bien laver
bravo j'aime les enfants propres et pour
vous récompenser nous allons jouer au
corbillon
un petit jeu calbut facile asseyons-nous
là ce petit panier est encore billon je
vous le passez en disant je te passe mon
corps billon qui mettons et il faut
répondre par un mot se terminant par oh
et si on ne le trouve pas on paie à car
c'est facile
oui eh bien nicolas je te passe mon
corps billon qui mettons
[Musique]
tu as perdu un gage
à pimprenelle je te passe mon corps
billon qui
moto3 bien
aimé à la gt bassement corbillon kim
était bon
non nicolas pimprenelle bien de le dire
tu dois dire à nos annonceurs peut pas
jouer avec nicolas tu vas bien c'est un
bébé il sait pas comment qu'est ce que
j'ai entendu
veut vous en dire moi des mois à vous
allez voir un thon de un peu des ans des
noms des saucissons débat non mais les
gros
oui
on veut voir thomas frey pauvre nour à
présent que j'ai reçu le panier dans
l'oeil
je lui donne un gros baiser ça sera fini
oui mais
voilà c'était un petit peu plus qu'un
oui tu peux revenir se fini mon hall va
mieux
non une autre fois nicolas pour ce soir
c'est terminé fait lapin et aller vite
on lui moi je pense bien ses deux filles
et moi
je n'avais plus à lons où je vais me
fâcher et embrassez vous
c'est bien pour te faire plaisir
pour toi
holy
sagement
[Musique]
bonne nuit petit garnement
en or mais vous vite
[Musique]
alors nounours comment s'est passé ce
petit jeu des familles ne m'en parlez
pas patron j'ai failli avoir un oeil au
beurre noir
ça se passera mieux la prochaine fois
oui alors aux eaux bonnes idées petits
faute de boer eux
[Musique]